hello everyone and welcome to tonight's
episode of beginner breakdown my name as
always is alex mullering and i'm excited
to show you our
lesson for tonight let me give one quick
heads up i'll remind you at the end as
well um but we're actually going to be
switching the nights for this class so
next week
uh
monday i believe it's the 29th of august
we're actually going to be having rose
2000 at this time and then tuesday the
day after we will be having a beginner
breakdown so for all those loyal fans
who enjoy it on monday nights i want to
give you the heads up we are going to be
moving to tuesday and i hope you can
join us but if not remember that uh even
if you can't come live will still be
available afterwards on youtube uh when
the episode is uploaded so stick around
for the series at least in that space
if you'd like to
now last week
we um
we were looking at the lucina position
which involves
both sides having just a king and a rook
and one side having a pawn
and we contrasted that with the filidor
position and we didn't really get to get
into the weeds with the philidor
and so i thought about doing that
tonight but
i wasn't confident in my ability to
fully explain the intricacies of that
position for beginners yet so i decided
to postpone that and instead wanted to
just have a fun week
and one of the really fun things about
chess something that really gets your
blood flowing is the idea of the queen
sacrifice
we've seen these in master games maybe
you've had some in your own games but
it's hard not to get excited when a
queen is sacrificed out of the blue
and leads to a victory
so i thought tonight i would look at
some of those uh some really famous
games in history that have queen
sacrifices but i also want to show
um not just hear something cool about
chess but also how we can maybe try and
apply the ideas of these in our games
and to do that i'm going to break it
into checkmating patterns
so this first one that's already on the
board here should look pretty familiar
to a lot of people
if you're not familiar this is called
the smothered mate pattern
and the idea
is
the king is fully enclosed in all of
these pieces right so there's a rook and
some ponds you can change it up in other
scenarios but basically the king is
fully stuck in the middle of the board
or sorry at one edge just completely
enclosed by their own pieces
and because the knight is able to jump
we can deliver this really nice
checkmate knight to c7 where normally
just having one knight i mean we have a
pawn over here but a knight on its own
normally wouldn't be able to deliver a
checkmate since black has locked the
king in such a way
we're able to get this smothered mate
now how does this connect with queen
sacrifices well there's a few ways
but this is one of the kind of one of my
favorite ways to introduce this smother
mate pattern so again this will be the
first of several different kinds of
checkmating patterns we're going to look
at but if you haven't seen this position
before
take a second and see if you can find
the winning sequence for white
and keep in mind it's going to involve
this smothered mating idea so how do you
think white should play
to get an advantage either our live
audience or if you're in the chat you're
welcome to suggest some answers as well
well it's all right if you're not too
sure this one is a little tough but what
we want to do is we want to end up
having the king fully surrounded by
pieces now in this particular position
we have a little bit of a trouble
troubling situation ourselves
where
we are down in material right we only
have our knights versus this rook and
pawn
so we are down three points
additionally our king is not in the best
position
if our queen moves too far away
probably not there somewhere like here
where it won't be traded
uh we are going to face this really
annoying move queen to a1
and probably will lead to a back rank
checkmate in most positions if our queen
moves away
so we need to do something very forcing
the good news for us is because of the
nice position of our pieces we have some
forcing options that can lead us to win
this game
so if you haven't found it that's okay
i'm going to spoil this one but we'll
have another practice example in just a
moment but the nice move here is to play
knight to f7 check
the idea is kind of two-fold we're
hitting the king with the knight
and there's a problem black has two
moves you can either move the king or
you can take the knight but neither of
these are going to work
if you take the knight then we have a
very simple way to win this game
it is not to take the rook which would
again lead to black back ranking us
on a1 we would have to block with the
queen but then they would take the queen
instead it is to realize that rook was
doing too much it was guarding the
square of f7 but also guarding the queen
so if they take here we will happily eat
their queen
and get a back rank ourselves
this is no good
so instead black sees this threat and is
a very simple move king to g8
now the position is back in our hands
and we need to do something very careful
right
now something to notice is because our
queen is lined up with the knight and
the king if we move our knight we're
going to get a discovery a discovery is
any tactic where you move a piece and
the piece behind it reveals an attack in
this case it would be a discovered check
the problem is if we just bring our
knight back to where it was
um even though we're calling check it's
not a big issue for black because they
are attacking our queen
and can simply remove the piece
we have to be a little more creative
than just you know making a discovery
here we actually have to use another
tactic related to discovery called a
double check
in this case the move is knight to h6
with the idea
that we are now attacking the king with
two pieces the queen and the knight
and you cannot take either of them right
if you take the queen the knight is
still calling check if you take the
knight the queen is still calling check
a double check forces the king to move
and the only safe space is king to h8
and here is where we get to our queen
sacrifice remember for the smothered
mate pattern we need the king to be
fully enclosed and the only way to do
that is for them to get their rook onto
g8
but they're not just going to
voluntarily put it there for us so
instead we can coax them along with the
really nice move queen to g8 check
this is forcing a response and because
our knight is placed to defend the queen
the king can't take it the work has to
take and we can finish it off with
knight to f7 checkmate
so this is our smothered mate sequence
the king is fully smothered by all of
these pieces
and we use a nice queen sacrifice to do
it
another practice example of this
position
comes right here
so again notice for part of this pattern
what's really important is the queen is
lined up with the king and we have our
knight in between sarnath is going to be
able to move and make this threat now in
this case it's different our queen is
not under attack so we don't have to get
any kind of double check here which is
good because we can't the knight and the
king are on these diagonal squares
there's no move our knight can play to
call check
but the question is where should we put
our knight to get the maximum benefit
here
any fonts where should we put our knight
to get the most power out of this
position
c5 exactly knight to c5 revealing the
attack and critically we're controlling
these really important squares around
the king
and now um again it doesn't matter that
the knight's in danger because this is a
discovered check
and technically the best move for here
for black is to block with the queen but
this is really just delaying the
inevitable so if black doesn't want to
just give up a queen
which won't change anything it'll just
make it one move longer
they're gonna have to move their king
now the best move here would be to play
king to b8
if you play king to d8 the problem is
remember our knight is controlling this
really pivotal square
so queen to d7 would just be checkmate
after king to b8 the problem remains the
same
this actually reverts us right back to
our original position and now we can set
up to get the the double check checkmate
first we bring our knight to d7
to call check with the knight and
there's nothing that can interrupt this
trick
and then the critical move here we bring
our knight to b6
double check you can't take the knight
and our knight needs to defend the
square where the king is going to be so
that we can sacrifice
once again king to d8 will just lead to
queen to d7 checkmate defended by the
knight
so the king goes to b8
but now just like last time we can
sacrifice our queen here on c8
and after the rook takes the only move
knight to d7 is checkmate so this is a
very important pattern to know
but it comes up in some really uh
awesome master games um one of them here
is one of the games known as the
immortal games there's a series of these
that after the game they've been so
commentators and masters alike just
think they're such excellent beautiful
games that they are called immortal so
this is actually the boston immortal uh
played white had franklin uh sorry white
was played by franklin young and uh
black was played by el dor or dore not
sure how to pronounce that name
but this happened in boston in the late
1800s
and we're not going to break down the
specifics of the game it was a finnish
gambit of sorts
um i am going to show you the main idea
and what processed here and how it ends
in our really fantastic queen sacrifice
so white is not worried about capturing
this pawn really want to prioritize
development um hoping that if black
takes they can recapture with the bishop
and just have their bishop pair their
knight ready to get involved
and really set up a nasty attack
black chooses to take on e4
castle
and knight to d6
a bit of a weird move blocking this pawn
but looking to threaten the bishop
and try and you know
exchange some of white's aggressive
pieces
white now plays a really kind of wild
move knight takes c3
allowing the bishop to be captured
which black takes
rook to e1 check
okay
black is the reasonable move the trip to
block
knight to d5 now we see why
black
white allowed black to take their bishop
they wanted knight to c3 to come with
this really devastating tempo
threatening to win the bishop
in this position black plays knight to
c6 to defend
and trip to g5
one of the rules with a pinned piece
right this is a pin where the bishop
can't move because then the king would
be in check
you want to attack pinned pieces you
want to put lots of pressure on them and
so white is doing an excellent job
pressuring this position black plays f6
and
white plays another good move plays rook
to c1
offering up i would like to take this
bishop
we can take the knight so we'll trade
material but then the rook on c4 will be
ready to swing over
double on the e file and put even more
pressure on this bishop
black declines this trade and plays b5
and white
takes it anyway does not care that this
is defended what's the idea here well
after the pawn takes
now knight to e5 kind of an incredible
looking move
really hard to break it down
but the basic idea in the game black
responds by taking the bishop had they
taken this knight
it doesn't really change anything or
let's say they take with the knight
if they take white is ready to actually
sacrifice this work as well
threatening again to win here on e7 and
if we see something like pawn takes
then bishop takes and the queen is
trapped
um lots of threats in this position
in the game
takes bishop
and we have queen to h5 check and here's
where i want you to start putting on
your thinking cap
b6 to block
and now we're entering the kind of
critical position
white to move
and keep in mind we're eventually going
to work towards a smothered mate it's
kind of incredible how this happens but
there's a lot of tactical ideas white
has given up a lot of material
in order to make this attack happen but
now it's all going to pay off
white needs to do something really
spectacular here to try and win this
game
so what would you play if you had the
white pieces
a knight g6 very very reasonable move um
by ruth rufixka i believe is how you say
your name uh yeah this is a really
normal idea especially when there's kind
of sacrifices after something like f6
and the queen comes to h5
the idea with knight to g6 is after the
pawn takes
the rook is not defended anymore
and this might be good enough to win
actually it's not this is good enough to
draw so knight takes sorry knight to g6
is a very good move but black actually
has a way to draw if they take we can
take here
king to f7 only move something like
queen to h7 check
king to f8
and we can put a lot of pressure on
uh but remarkably black is going to be
able to survive this position
they have just enough resources out here
to get a draw
and we can continue with perpetual but
nothing better the 956 is a really nice
looking idea
there's a move we have to do first
and in the game franklin young found it
it's knight to f6
the idea being now if you take this
knight
which you have to right if you play king
2 f8 this is not going to be any good
because of queen to h6
all of these squares are covered
you have to take the knight
once you do now we can play knight takes
g6
we activate this with a check and we're
getting our final piece involved really
a remarkable move here
in the game
black blocks this check with the queen
somewhat surprisingly but it kind of
becomes clear why if you look at the
other options if they play something
like
knight to block for instance
then we actually have checkmate in two
moves
knight takes h8 and queen to f7
checkmate
if instead you block with the bishop it
isn't much better
here you might see something like knight
to e5 check
and queen f7 again the same idea
so there's not really much there you can
do
if you try something like k2 f7 this
also isn't gonna work we might see
something like knight to e5
and where the king has a lot of places
to go but wherever you go it's not
pleasant um for instance if you go king
to let's say uh e7 then we have knight
take c6 check
forking the queen and the king the rook
is still involved checkmate is probably
coming very soon
something like king g7 we have queen to
f7
and
another nice checkmate there's really
not much that i can do here which is why
in the game queen to e7 instead with
rook takes c7
trip takes
now
he stay resistance knight to 5
and we begin to see the problem if you
notice this is the same pattern we
started with
the king only has two options either to
go to f8 or to d8
if you go to f8 it is immediately
checkmate on f7 so king to d8
and we have our smother mate pattern the
knight comes in and calls check
check
to e8 forcing the rook to capture
because it's defended by the knight and
our beautiful smothered techmate
white wins with only the only piece they
have is this night they've given
everything else up a really beautiful
game the boston immortal
feel free to check it out and look in
more details but this is just a
beautiful end
and actually the smother made sequence
also is how the game of the century ends
this was between donald byrne and bobby
fischer in 1956 one of the most famous
games of all time
and it's a very complex game we're not
going to go into all the details
um
i want to get to our ending position
so lots of ideas happening
we get to this kind of interesting
middle game where
uh the king once king is exposed black
has sacrificed some material
and it's a very imbalanced position
uh
instead of saving the queen
black plays an inner meso and calls neck
king goes and hides on f1
and
that plays this really remarkable bobby
fischer incredible move bishop to e6
allowing the queen to be taken and even
more surprisingly in the game it wasn't
bishop takes e6 um if the queen had been
taken um there are
a few different ideas but the main way
black would probably try and get an
advantage
is again with check and then doing
similar to this mother made sequence but
without the queen
we're going to just kind of loop our
opponent
and win some extra material
and would be a very imbalanced position
but i would essentially argue that yes
you have the queen but all of my pieces
are incredibly active and dangerous and
your king is stuck and your rook is
doing nothing um you actually need this
knight to stay here to guard the
backrank checkmate
so really kind of incredible complex
position here
i want to focus on what actually happens
in the game because uh donald byrne did
not take the queen he kind of saw this
is not working out in the long run and
decided to take the bishop
and here bobby finished the game really
in style queen to b5 check
in the game bishop to c4 was played was
delaying the inevitable
we've seen this all before
knight comes here to call check and line
up with the queen when the king returns
knight to g3 double check
to f1
and knight to e2 a really beautiful
queen sacrifice checkmate
smothered me pattern is something
important to keep in mind
um because it can happen in your games
but this is kind of the first way we
might look for sacrificing a queen to
get a nice checkmate
the next one i want to look at is the
opera me
this actually comes from
the famous game morphy's opera house
which was played by paul morphy we're
actually going to look at that game in a
moment
but the basic idea of the opera mate is
the bishop and rook are working together
to cut off all of the king's escape uh
when the work lands on d8 it's also
going to cut off these two squares and
usually either one of our other pieces
or one of black's pieces will be in the
way in this case i've put a pawn on f7
but after rook to d8
there's no safe square for the black
king to go
some examples of this position
i'm actually going to flip the board
here for black
would be something like this
um
in this position
wake or sorry black can choose to
sacrifice their queen by playing queen
to d1 check
and after the bishop takes the only move
now the rook comes in
and works with the bishop to deliver
this checkmate
so again this is an example of this
pattern
see if you can find how black can
achieve a similar
winning position
in
this example here so it's black to move
what would you do to
win this game
queen to f1 yes we need the king on this
square so that when we move our bishop
we will call check with the rook
now
where should we put the bishop
yes
another double check always an important
resource to look out for there's no time
to block uh the check with the rook or
to take the bishop
king has to move and we finish it off
with rook to f1 and again we see this
same pattern all of these squares are
occupied
this is
um in morphe's opera house the game
itself very famous uh there's hundreds
if not thousands of lectures on this
game
i'm not going to go through all the
details
morphe has the white pieces and he
continues to put pressure on white's
king
eventually he makes this really nice
sacrifice
night for two pawns
with the idea
that black's king is too open and
white's pieces have such strong control
over this position that it's very hard
for black to survive and in fact black
doesn't
knight to b7 queensland castle
and
uh paul morphy sacrifices his rook
for the knight
knowing that one worst case he can win
it back um but also to bring his other
rook into the game
to e6 and here is where we get really
nice position
chip takes d7
knight captures
and morphy wins the game in two moves
using this opera pattern he needs to get
his rook and his bishop working together
so how does he do it
yes we need to deflect this knight it is
in the way if it if it moved then this
is checkmate and we can do that with
queen to b8
there's no move to stop the check other
than to take the queen
and now rook to d8 is checkmate
um the same pattern happens in several
other games
one really nice example another famous
one is called the sucker punch game it's
only 11 moves long um but richard ready
had the white pieces against tardikower
and this happened in
early 1900s
um but the main idea of this game
is
black seemingly gives up this pawn on e5
the white is up upon
instead of trading queens which would
just let keep the pawn
black plays this check
and recaptures this way ultimately
probably not the best idea because
notice that white has a lot of
development but black is thinking that
this knight is pinned and could be a
very easy target if white tries to
defend it with something like f3
there could be some consequences black
can kind of continue to build pressure
in this position
white plays this really surprising move
though
queenside castle
now black sees okay well you didn't
defend the night so i'm gonna take it if
you take with the queen then rookie one
pins the queen to the king
so black chooses to take with the knight
and this falls right into richard
reddy's trap
how does reddy win this game
keep in mind the kind of opera mating
pattern we just looked at
i'm sorry
so we could play work to e1 and it's
possible this might help us out um we
might be able to win the night back um
after something like
uh say they play bishop to f5 or pawn to
f5 we can still play f3 and we might be
able to win the night back but there's
actually something even better
and someone with a funny name in the
chat has found the right move
queen to d8
really nice and notice again how the
bishop and the rook are online the king
has no moves you have to take
and now the really nice move uh bishop
to
g5
hitting the king
in double check
you can't block or take in either
instance because you're still in check
from the other one the king has to move
um in the game i believe rook or sorry
king to e8 is played allowing for the
opera mate
even if the king goes to d7 you still
can't escape because of trip to d8
checkmate
so another really nice example oops
let's go back to here we go
another really nice example of the opera
pattern one final one this was a blitz
game between mikhail tal
fan favorite and tigron patrosian the
iron tiger
played in 1975
and also a relatively short game this
one i believe only 21 moves
trojan is playing kind of very solid
very safe a french style structure with
these knights ready to cover all of the
center squares not trying to give white
much space
but what happens here
is white manages to open things up a
little bit
and then make some really incredible
sacrifices you know what paul is known
for
and this is the first example
after queen to a4 the position is dead
even
and instead of uh taking the queen
and trading something like this i also
note that you can't try and win this
knight even though there's two attackers
because after knight takes
um
queen takes and we have lost the queen
as a defender so this also doesn't win a
piece
um
mikael towel plays a really nice move c4
with the idea that well wait a minute
isn't this just a free knight
because there's a pin here right
the caltel does not care about that he
happily recaptures the knight and black
eats this rook the black is up a full
rook
um
now we do get this knight back so black
is dressed up the exchange
but um tal is banking on this idea that
black's king has not castled and now the
queen is on a one so it really needs to
get back into the game
um so there's some time that needs to be
spent
the trojan plays queen to a6 to try and
get the involved even that's going to be
a little too late rook to e1 and this
king is very exposed in the center
a queenside castle's not the move you
would like to play when you have an open
c file
but you need to get the king to safety
and it's going to take too long to get
the bishop out of the way there's just
too much pressure
on the center and on white's king sorry
i'm black's king
queenside castle
jump to f4
and rook takes d5
black seems to be you know recovering
um there is a bit of a problem though
c1 check and the king goes to d8
now
took the g5 attack
in this position
into e8 is played f6 doesn't really work
because there's a nice sacrifice on f6
white is going to be able to pick up the
rook
oops there's a bit of a spoiler
um and also if f6 uh if [ __ ] after
bishop takes ben king to e8 well
why didn't you just play king d8 in the
first place now you've lost the pawn
so
so king to e8 is played in this position
another really fantastic move knight to
e5
what's the idea here well
unfortunately black does not have time
to take the queen
if rook takes queen
then we have basically the opera mate
rook to c8 check
and with the knight covering this last
square
it's okay that the rook started on the c
file rook has to drop back to d8 and
this is exactly the opera main
now trojan sees the threat and doesn't
just take the queen
but trojan plays the move b6 to defend
c8 with the queen but this opens up
another problem
mikhail town now deflects patrons queen
with this really nice move queen to a4
check
and after queen takes a four because the
queen is not defended so what else is
there
c8 is no longer defended and the game
ends with this really nice opera
checkmate pattern
so another really good one to keep in
mind
okay we've looked at the smother mate
we've looked at the opera mate
i have three more for you
the first one is anastasia's mate um
this is a very simple idea but it's kind
of like a back rank um except it
involves the knight so in this case the
knight is covering both b6
and b8
black's king is stuck on this single row
and so in this position we can play the
move rook to a3 and this is going to be
checkmate so the knight is cutting off
these really crucial escape squares and
we're going to be able to use this to
our advantage so here's the first
practice example
white to move and using anastasia's mate
find the winning sequence
what should white play here
knight e7 a really nice start so we're
going to get a forcing move and we're
putting our knight in position to guard
all of these squares
okay only one move king to h8
yes and here's the queen sacrifice we
don't need this queen anymore because
now we've gotten rid of the pawn the
knight is covering all these squares and
we have this really nice work to h5
checkmate
a similar pattern can be seen in this
position it's actually the exact same
pattern just on a different side of the
board
start with knight to e2 the king has to
move and you can sacrifice the queen on
h2
because of rook two h6
now there's a really uh cool game here
one of magnus carlson's uh early kind of
[Music]
i don't know the word for it but people
started to look out for this kid after
this game um he was playing um john
ludwig hammer in 2003
and he had the black pieces and had a
really nice winning sequence so again a
complicated game even though it's short
worth looking up but the basic ideas are
as follow
so carlson seems to be playing kind of a
pierce or queens indian style setup it
is now
our kings in it now appears because e4
has come on the board
without c4
um
both sides are getting kind of set up
and developed
five striking at the center
and knight to h5
magnus's intentions are likely to start
trying to attack
the uh
king side of the board so he's putting
his pieces in position to do so
pawn takes pawn
and instead of simply recapturing
knight to f4 is played
a termeso targeting this bishop which is
not defended so there's no time to
recapture the pawn
the bishop goes to b5 and now magnus
recaptures on e5
knight takes knight
and again another inner meso instead of
recapturing the knight with the bishop
or the pawn
magnus plays queen to g5
and there's no time to save the knight
because we're threatening checkmate
there's also a threat of knight takes h3
because this pawn is pinned so those
both need to be dealt with
knight to g4 was the solution saving the
piece that was destined to be recaptured
on e5 but unfortunately this also
allows for queen takes b5 magnus picks
up peace anyway
knight to b3
and magnus plays knight to e2 check
which seems a little questionable
after knight to b3
bishop is packing the knight so we need
to do something here
but most people would be worried that
after knight to e2 this knight is going
to get lost on the fray right white has
a lot of control over this area of the
board and it's going to be hard for this
knight to escape unscathed what is
magnus thinking well let's see
it goes to h1
takes g4 okay we've gotten rid of this
knight
now rook a to e8
trip to e3 a fortifying defense of all
of these escape squares for the night
and preparing to activate a work
potentially
rook takes e4
and rook to e1 seeming to
fully drop this knight and uh john
ludwig hummer is saying what are you
doing kid
magnus was i think only
he was very young at this time in 2003
and where does this thing go there's no
way to defend it
but in this position magnus plays an
absolutely crushing move
any ideas oh hello welcome from egypt
glad to have you in our stream
how should magnus continue here it seems
like the knight is trapped
yes really brilliant queen sacrifice
queen to h5 check
with the problem is it's not exactly at
a stage to mate because the king is not
you know blocked from both of these
squares but the knight on e2 is doing a
very crucial job of keeping the king
trapped on the side of the board
the only way to stop checkmate is to
take the queen but now rook to h4
is checkmate so anastasia's mate another
one to keep in your wheelhouse uh can
come in handy in some very cool
circumstances
all right we're down to two more
uh the next mating pattern i want to
look at is called pillsbury's mate the
idea here is pretty simple
you have kind of a normally castled king
but crucially this pawn is missing or we
find some way to get rid of it
and our bishop is just dominating these
squares around the king so that you can
play a move like rook to g1
and
win the game the rook and the bishop
together so this mating pattern is
called pillsbury's mate
in this position
there's a bit of a problem we want to
get this pillsbury's made sequence but
unfortunately our bishop is not on the
right side right we need the bishop to
be looking into this corner to cut off
all these squares and our bishop is on
h6
so how should we
continue as white to find this checkmate
what would you do
okay good way to start work to g1 check
and black only has one move king to h8
okay bishop g7 and the king has to
return f6
exactly and this is just checkmate um
we've used this kind of nice
check and then discovered check
to force the king to go where we want
him to go
and now we can get our bishop on the
right square and align our rook
a really nice
kind of sequence to know
right keep this one in mind it comes up
a decent amount of the time
a little more complicated
but we're going to end up with a similar
pattern the things to know in this
position
certainly we have our rooks
lined up and ready in our queen a lot of
danger here in this file now we can't
just play checkmate immediately because
there is a knight defending g7
also note that we have our bishops ready
and open to attack
so what is the way we can actually win
this game how does white get checkmate
in this position
a little more complicated than the last
one
okay so stacking the queen on g7 um
knight takes would be the only move
how would you continue from there
okay and we're actually going to get
something very similar to last time
rook g7 check and now we have our bishop
on the right diagonal and the rook here
but there is a bit of a problem
how do we actually finish our food in
this case
it's a little trickier than it looks
yeah rook g8 very well found
and it's important right because so a
lot of people would just say what if i
just bring the rook back somewhere and
shouldn't i get the same thing well the
problem here is now we give black the
opportunity to
block in some way maybe something like
knight to e5 or even f6 and shut down
our bishop
we don't have time to do that so she
found and as uh
a wiganer 88 in the chat found as well
rook to g8
um
is a double check this is forcing the
king to move
so king takes and now the main idea is
we have time to bring our other rook
into the game rook to g1
check and
there are no moves for the king the only
way to stop checkmate is to block with
the queen
and rook takes delivering checkmate
really nice sequence
well what game does this one come up
there was a really cool game uh between
david janowski and friedrich samish in
1925
um that actually features this mating
pattern so uh kenowski have the white
pieces
and we start out with
um the nimzo indian structure bishop to
g5 and c5
and again we're not going to go too deep
into the openings um this is almost now
kind of morphed into some kind of london
system except the bishops on g5
both sides are playing relatively
standard ideas
white kind of forming this battery
plaque hoping to get their rooks
involved in the game
and white strikes with h4 rather than
castling or doing something safe uh h4
with the idea that after h6
uh queen to d2 and if you take
then we can retake with the pawn and
activate our rook and this is quite
scary um samish did not want to open up
the rook this is kind of the same
um as the fishing pole maneuver and it's
a it's very dangerous for black in this
position
so instead of doing something like this
again the knight's going to have to move
and this is going to be very bad
for
knight to g4 was played opening up the
bishop as well trying to get a lot of
pressure in this position
the bishop drops back to f4
e6 saving the queen
knight to e3 hoping to trade and there
is a trade of these knights
pawn to h5 hoping to kind of lock down
white's attempts to press forward
but uh this still gives away a nice
opportunity white says okay i need to
attack your king
i'm going to lift my rook to do so
e5 played
pawn takes knight takes
and there's a big trade here in the
center
takes attacking the queen
and trip to
a6 with the idea that now maybe you have
to move your bishop somewhere and
there's threats of rook coming to v8 the
king is still in the center
so black is hoping that
they will have some nice compensation
and some pressure for the pawn they have
given up on e5
but in this position white has a really
really nice move i believe the only
winning move
to
complete this game
how does white continue and
really find a beautiful move in this
position
and again keep in mind our pillsbury's
mating pattern we just looked at
yeah i see a few people in chat with the
right idea
wagoner 88 and lost leon 1234 glad to
have a first time chatter here
the excellent move here is queen to h6
exclamation points we are sacrificing
the queen
but not by taking a piece we're actually
this isn't a forcing move
there's no checks there's no captures um
but black is just totally lost here
um
you can't take the queen which i believe
is what happens in the game
um
because of pillsbury's right which we'll
see in a moment and nothing else really
works right because both of these
bishops are threatening you can't
stop them both very easily right you
can't take here because queen to h7 is
mate
and we can't play f6 to stop the threat
this way because we still have queen to
h7 something like king to h7 and there's
different ways to win this bishop to g6
is a very strong move
but perhaps the simplest would be
something like just trading on d6
and then playing rook to e3 to keep the
king locked away
threatening
bishop to g6 checkmate
and you might see something like rook h8
opening up space for the king
they took the g6
and if king to f8 and queen takes h8
checkmate
um
that's just one possible line there's
other ways black could have played
six is going to be losing in every
variation
so instead
we have g takes h6
and now very simply rook to g3
checkmates
really beautiful pillsbury's mate here
another one to keep in your back pocket
and i want to show you one more mating
pattern so we've already looked at the
smothered mate the aquamate anastasia's
mate and now pillsbury's mate the last
one i want to show you is bowden's mate
because this is actually going to lead
us into
probably my favorite chess game of all
time this was the first sketches game i
remember watching and getting super
excited about the game
and so the basic idea with bowden's mate
is it involves both of the bishops
and they're going to be cutting off the
light and dark squares by swinging
across to opposite sides
of the king
in this position
all of these squares are cut off
and there's usually some other material
or other pieces we have that are keeping
these last two escape squares off the
table
so
here's an example
white to move and win
and you have to be careful about how you
do it but there's a very nice
winning sequence here involving odin's
mate
so wait to move what would you play
and
yes knight c7 check uh with the idea
that after bishop takes
yes uh and you have to take here first
right bishop e5 doesn't work immediately
because we have c6
knight takes is a forcing move um
putting off all the options because we
have this pawn nicely placed on e6
there is no space the king can go
and after you take there's nothing left
to block this is checkmate
very nicely found
here's our second example
i'm going to move and find the winning
sequence here
and while you're thinking about that uh
someone in the chat is it just me or do
chess players back then allow the game
to proceed to mate instead of resigning
when it's clear or lost yeah a lot of
games they end in resignation um i think
back in the day there was a more
romantic sense to it they liked to you
know see these really pretty positions
on the board
today
people just know the game so well and
know their opponents that um they
realize i don't need to have it shown
you can find it in an engine later but
there is something nice about this kind
of romantic style of chess
okay in this position
i see lost leon again has the right
suggestion in this position really
stunning move
queen to f6
check
with the idea that black's king is fully
encompassed and our bishop is dominating
these light squares
the only way to stop this is to take the
queen
allowing our second bishop to get
involved and cut off all of the
remaining squares bones made really
really beautiful
and this leads us to
perhaps my favorite chess game of all
time i'm going to spend a little bit
more time on this one just because i
appreciate it so much
and i have some history enjoying this
game
this is called the peruvian immortal
earlier we looked at the boston immortal
game
but this one was played by a peruvian
master of chess named esteban canal and
he was playing against an anonymous
player in budapest in 1934
the game begins with esteban having the
white pieces and he plays pawn to e4
black continues d5 the scandinavian
defense
not as popular these days but um at the
high level still a very popular opening
among average players
and the one plays the main idea the pawn
and attack the queen with thanks to c3
in this position there's a few things
you can do most of the time you will
either play queen to a5 and queen to d8
although there is growing popularity for
this move queen to d6
in our game we have queen to a5 hoping
to keep the queen semi-active perhaps
get it on a nice diagonal to pin the
knight to the king
and something to note in these types of
scandinavian positions is a very
important move will often be this pawn
to c6 to give the queen a nice escape
back home
but let's see how the game continues
white plays pawn to d4 picking up space
in the center
on to c6 as we just said giving the
queen an escape if she needs it often
you will see something like uh bishop to
d2 chest dojo live thank you for the
raid welcome in everybody uh we'll be
wrapping up here in about 10 minutes but
we're looking at the peruvian immortal
game one of my favorite chess games of
all time
um in this position it's white to move
so black just played c6 with the idea
that um you want to give the queen an
escape
often in these variations white will
play something eventually like bishop to
d2 and then try tricky moves like knight
to b5 hoping to get some forks with the
discoveries on the queen
so black is kind of preempting that and
preparing just to bring the queen back
to d8 if things get a little dangerous
white continues very simply with
development knight to f3
and [ __ ] up to g4 hitting the knight
immediately
black doesn't want any shenanigans here
and is seems content to trade off the
light squared bishop for the night
white plays bishop to f4 developing the
bishop to a nice active square in the
center putting more controls on e5 uh
knight to f3 was controlling the square
but now with the pin um it is perhaps
easier for black to try and play this
move white would like to prevent that
and so instead black plays the simple
move c6 and this is a very common pawn
setup you will see
black wants to get the bishop out before
they play e6 so that the bishop is not
blocked in but now this is a very solid
setup the pawns are going to control all
of these light squares
and
this dark squared bishop will often come
in and try and fight for the rest of
them
so
white plays h3 asking the bishop if it
really wants to stick around or if it's
just going to trade
and
a player of the black pieces true system
trade
and queen to f3
now we have trip to b4 so this is a
decent looking move uh pinning the
knights forming kind of this battery
with the queen
i'm sorry the knight was already pinned
but we're adding pressure and
locking down this knight
really trying to gain control over here
and there's not really a threat like in
some positions you might play something
like a3 to take the bishop
but that's not really a concern because
the queen is on a5 and so the rook will
be hanging right this pawn will be
pinned
so not really something that uh black
has to worry about here
and yeah a decent looking move although
i might say again given what i just said
about this pawn structure
it seems like this bishop might be more
important as a defensive resource and an
offensive one
to cover all of these gaps especially
looking at how
commanding white's light squared bishop
is on f4
the white plays bishop to e2 looking
just a castle perhaps get out of the pin
[Music]
e7
and this is a very interesting move that
immediately
i think sparks an idea in esteban
canal's mind and you may have had this
idea already um
but i'm sorry after bishop and knight e7
or knight d7
um this is uh it looks like a very
normal looking move right developing the
knight controlling some of these dark
squares that we already talked about
maybe being a little weaker
but this is kind of the first piece of
the puzzle that's going to lead to one
of my favorite checkmates of all time
in the game esteban plays the move a3
which is a little bit confusing right as
we just talked about
um it seems like there's not really a
threat to take this bishop
so perhaps the idea is white wants to
just prepare
for once they have castled
and connected these rooks to then have
this pawn activate as a threat
um we don't really know the rating of
esteban's opponent here so it could be
reasonable that he's kind of switching
up the move order to maybe try and
confuse his opponent
instead of castling and then playing a3
maybe he's doing this first and maybe
his opponent will forget about it
i'm not really sure what's going on in
his mind or his opponents
but it's a kind of an interesting move
here a3 and it's the start of a really
nice sequence
black is you know as we've said not
afraid of this threat there's a pin on
this rook it's actually even worse than
a pin because if you take you're not
just losing one rook you're probably
going to lose both of them
although maybe white can block but this
is not going to look ideal for white
so black just plays a very sensible move
in castle's queen side
um this may be a little questionable
given again how much control this bishop
has and as we will see that is an
extremely relevant feature of the
position
maybe it would have been a little wiser
to try and play something like knight to
f6 or knight to e7 and then kingside
castle
um but black wants to i guess really
quickly develop and perhaps put their
work on the d file without you know
wasting time with their king being
in the center of the board
so this is the move they play
and in this position it's white to move
and find a really excellent idea
so if you have
white what would be
going through your mind what might you
play and see if you can find the best
sequence
in this position
while you're thinking about it i'll just
give you some more to kind of take note
of
perhaps black is arguing that since
white has not castled right this would
looks like a very natural move for
castling to unpin the knight and to
connect the rooks um
perhaps black is arguing that since
white has not castled um their castling
is going to you know counteract the fact
that they haven't developed their night
yet and maybe they're still deciding
where they want to put this knight maybe
they don't want to deal with the pin
but this is maybe some of what's going
on in black's mind so a very natural
move would just be to castle but white
has something a little sneakier in mind
and a few of you in the chat have
already found the idea i'll give you one
more minute because it's just such a
really beautiful idea
all right well i hope you're ready for
uh one of my favorite moves in all of
chess just such a fun position
in this position white plays the really
incredible move pawn takes on b4 maybe i
spoiled it a little bit by showing how
much of it didn't make sense but there's
a really big problem here
in this position black plays the move
queen takes a1
and instead of blocking
white plays
king to d2 allowing
queen takes h1
what is white doing
esteban canal giving up two rooks how do
you finish this game why did you do this
well to wegener 88 in the chat um
boom
shakalaka
the really excellent queen sacrifice in
this position
is queen takes on c6 check
the bishop is covering all of these
squares
and um the only move in this position is
to take with the pawn
and now we see bowdoin's mate come alive
with bishop to a6 checkmate
cutting off all of the escape squares
there's nothing black can do
and if we go back and take a look it's a
really outrageous position i know um so
incredible
after one takes on uh b4
it's actually
uh almost just winning right now because
this
queen can't take the rook right the best
move would be to go somewhere to defend
um
but you can't just go back on the a file
obviously we have control of it and even
something like
queen to b6 i guess you can play this
way but you've already given up a bishop
and we've activated um white's rook
after queen takes a1
actually much better for white to play
this king to d2 move because if you
block with one of these pieces then
you're giving black a move to you know
pull the queen back somewhere
and survive but after king to d2 now
there's just nothing you can do because
the rook is attacking your queen and
you're either losing the game or you're
losing your queen
and you can't move the queen back
anywhere right anywhere that defends the
pawn
is covered by white's knight or bishop
it's a really incredible position
um
and after queen takes a1 king d2
knight e5 any good i don't think this is
going to solve the problem uh it's
clever you're kind of re-attacking our
queen but i think very simply we can
just take the knight
and
reactivate the threat
there's still this threat of queen
sacking and
everything seems the same
and i don't think there's an idea of
something like
rook d4
i'm not positive um
i think just bishop takes and
let's say queen takes h1
we should still be you know winning back
plenty of material
in something like this
um yeah 95
if you try and move the queen anywhere
or or open up the king yeah i don't i
think you're going to be able to stop
checkmate immediately but white's still
going to get plenty of compensation for
it because remember we first take this
bishop and you're going to have to give
up this rook and you're also going to
lose this one to even try and stay in
the game so it's not quite going to work
but it's a nice attempt it's a good
thing to look at you know kind of a
reverse kind of queen sack countering
one with the other
um but something good to look at but
it's such a fun position
i'm taking here allowing black to hang
themselves with moves like knight to d7
and then queen that castle and just
having such a beautiful control of these
diagonals let's see it one more time
queen takes a1 into d2 queen takes and
just this beautiful explosion queen
takes c6 and wins the game so keep these
patterns in mind you know if you want do
something like me and get inspired by
these master games
with these really beautiful checkmates
and see what you can learn how you can
apply them to your own games whether
it's the smothered mate the opera mate
anastasia's mate pillsbury's mate or
this bowden's mate and there's
dozens more so feel free to look into
them on your own thanks everybody for
coming i hope you enjoyed it and hope to
see you again next week as a reminder we
are going to be switching to tuesday
nights for beginner breakdown um monday
nights at this time will be road to 2000
so please stick around for both of those
but just be aware that we are going to
be switching the days for those two so
hope to see all again soon and hope you
have a great week take care